discovering your why is just the  beginning in order to enjoy  all the benefits of having a clearly  articulated why  you'll need to have the courage and  discipline to use it  like thomas edison said vision with that  execution  is hallucination there is an ideal order  for implementing your why  though sometimes reality does get in the  way and it all starts  with you our natural tendency is to  start with the tangible  we define our value by what we do so it  takes practice to start with why  like riding a bicycle at first we're  unsure unsteady  we're in our heads thinking about all  the things we need to do pedal fast keep  enough  speed so we don't fall over we have to  really concentrate  we may even fall over even scrape our  knees but we get back on the bike and  try again  and eventually it becomes natural  starting with why is no different